in the wake of the Israeli strike on
Rafa people are sifting through the
debris that once was their
home scene is difficult especially for
75-year-old Hisham AB na who Mourns the
loss of his entire family he says they
were killed trying to escape the
violence my family has been completely
wiped out from the Civil
register no one no child no woman
not a young one or old person survived
all of them are gone no one is left I'm
the only one remaining they're all gone
if I were sleeping inside a house I
would have died but I slept
outside many victims remain trapped
under the
[Music]
rubble Israeli operations from both air
and land are ravaging Central and
Southern
Gaza
here more casualties keep arriving at
the already struggling Hospital in
Bal in Han Unis nonstop bombing has
killed dozens of
civilians despite being designated as a
so-called safe zone for civilians by
Israel their homes have not been spurred
the
[Music]
attacks what else is left in Gaza
they are pushing us into a corner what
will we be at the end where should we go
what are they driving us to let us go
back to our homes even if we have to eat
dirt end this nonsense War
enough this aerial footage shows the
dire humanitarian crisis in southern
Gaza many people including women and
children form long accuses hoping for a
meal the only one they will likely have
all day but with overcrowded camps
limited Aid many are left with desperate
need hanim Mahmud Al jazer Rafa
Gaza make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz